In an earlier video, we looked at one of
the most egregious examples of fake
history. Georgetown University professor
John Espazito's famous claim that quote,
"5 centuries of peaceful coexistence
elapsed before political events and an
imperial papal power play led to
centuries long series of so-called holy
wars that pitted Christendom against
Islam and left an enduring legacy of
misunderstanding and distrust." That's
from his book, Islam, the Straight Path,
page 64. Espazito is saying that from
the very start, Muslims and Christians
had always lived in peaceful coexistence
until those pesky medieval Christians
decided to ruin it all by launching the
first crusade. In reality, however, and
as I discussed more thoroughly in the
previous video, those five centuries of
peaceful coexistence featured Islam
violently conquering threearters of the
Christian world with all the usual
massacres, mass enslavements, and the
systematic destruction of churches,
30,000 of them in just one year alone.
1009. The first crusade came in response
to all these ongoing attacks against
Christianity, which in the decades
before it was called for in 1095 had
further witnessed the slaughter
enslavement of tens, if not hundreds of
thousands of more Christians, especially
Armenians, according to Matthew of
Adessa, the chronicler. At any rate, and
as it happens, Espazito offers more
outlandish lies on the self-same page
where his famous five centuries of
peaceful coexistence quote appears after
mentioning how Pope Urban II called for
the first crusade at the council of
Claremont and how all the Christians in
attendance eagerly embraced it, crying
deos, meaning God wills a crusade be
launched. Espazito writes, quote, "This
was ironic because, as one scholar has
observed, God may indeed have wished it,
but there is certainly no evidence that
the Christians of Jerusalem did or that
anything extraordinary was occurring to
pilgrims there to prompt such a response
at that moment in history." Again,
that's from Islam, the straight path,
page 64. The scholar that Espazito
quotes is Francis E. Peters in his
essay, Early Muslim empires. Clearly,
this academic is as delusional or
dishonest as our Georgetown professor.
To claim that there is certainly no
evidence that the Christians of
Jerusalem desired aid against their
Muslim overlords who were terrorizing
them or that nothing extraordinary was
occurring to Christian pilgrims is
itself extraordinary, extraordinarily
fake. Here, for example, is what William
of Tier, born around 11:30, a near
contemporary chronicler, said of
Christian experiences in Jerusalem right
before the first
crusade. Quote, Jerusalem's Christians,
he writes, endured far greater troubles
under the Turks, so that they came to
look back upon as light the woes which
they had suffered under the yoke of the
Egyptians and Persians. Death threatened
them every day. And what was worse than
death? The fear of servitude, harsh and
intolerable. William is saying that
under the Turks who conquered Jerusalem
from the Egyptians around 1071,
Christians suffered even worse abuses
than under the fatimids of Egypt and the
Abbassads of Persia, which were bad
enough. He proceeds to offer a typical
example. Quote, "Even while the
Christians were in the very act of
celebrating the holy rights, the Turkish
enemy would violently force an entrance
into the churches which had been
restored and preserved with such
infinite difficulty since being
destroyed earlier under the Egyptians
and the Abbassads. Utterly without
reverence for the consecrated places,
they sat upon the very altars and struck
terror into the heart of the worshippers
with their mad cries and whistlings.
They overturned the chalicees, trod
underfoot the utensils devoted to the
divine offices, broke the marble
statues, and showered blows and insults
upon the clergy. The Lord Patriarch,
then in office, was dragged from his
seat by hair and beard and thrown to the
ground. Again and again he was seized
and thrust into prison without cause.
Treatment fit only for the lowest slave
was inflicted upon him in order to
torture his people who suffered with him
as with a father. As for European
pilgrims to Jerusalem prior to the first
crusade, Michael the Syrian born around
1126 writes, quote, "As the Turks were
ruling the lands of Syria and Palestine,
they inflicted injuries on Christians
who went to pray in Jerusalem. They beat
them, pillaged them, and levied the pole
tax, Jiza. Moreover, every time they saw
a caravan of Christians, particularly of
those from Rome and the lands of Italy,
they made every effort to cause their
death in diverse
ways. Such was the fate of one German
pilgrimage to Jerusalem in 1064.
According to one of the pilgrims, quote,
accompanying this journey was a noble
abbus, a headnun of graceful body and of
a religious outlook. Setting aside the
cares of the sisters committed to her
care, and against the advice of the
wise, she undertook this great and
dangerous pilgrimage. The pagans
captured her, and in the sight of all,
these shameless men gang raped her until
she breathed her last. To the dishonor
of all Christians. Christ's enemies
performed such abuses and others like
them on the Christians. Then there is
the fact that whichever city the first
crusaders liberated on their long trek
to Jerusalem, its indigenous Christians
regularly hurled themselves at and
kissed their feet in gratitude.
According to Fulture of Chartra, born
around 1059, a participant and
eyewitness of the first crusade, quote,
"When we passed by the villages of the
Armenians near Adessa, it was
astonishing to see them advance toward
us with crosses and standards, kissing
our feet and garments most humbly for
love of God, because they had heard that
we would defend them from the Turks
under whose yoke they had been oppressed
for a very long time."
In another instance near Bethlehem,
Fulture writes, quote, "When the
Christians, evidently Greeks and
Syrians, found that the Franks had come,
they were especially filled with great
joy." Christians also turned on the
Muslims and sided with the Franks on
multiple occasions, most notably the
liberation of Adessa. This is further
proof that they preferred to be ruled by
these strange newcomers from the West
rather than by the devil they knew. In
short, the indigenous Christians of
Jerusalem, starting with their spiritual
leader, the patriarch, were treated
horrifically. European pilgrims to
Jerusalem, including raped and murdered
women and children, were treated
horrifically. And wherever the European
crusaders passed through, the native
Christians, mostly Armenians, Syrians,
and some Greeks, threw themselves at
their feet in gratitude for rescuing
them from the abuses they constantly
experienced under Muslim rule.
Meanwhile, and as seen, Georgetown
professor John Espazito denies all of
that by quoting not contemporary sources
as I have been, but another academic,
Francis E. Peters, who to remind you
sarcastically claims that quote, "God
may indeed have wished it the liberation
of Jerusalem by the crusaders. But there
is certainly no evidence that the
Christians of Jerusalem did or that
anything extraordinary was occurring to
pilgrims there to prompt such a
response, meaning the first crusade at
that moment in history." Why all this
lying? Simple. to prove that the
crusades were unprovoked and unjust wars
which among other travesties brought an
end to five centuries of peaceful
coexistence. Thus, in the very next
sentence, after quoting Peter's absurd
claim that nothing extraordinary was
happening to the Holy Lands Christians
to justify a
crusade, Espazito makes his grand point.
Quote, "In fact, Christian rulers,
knights, and merchants were driven to
crusade primarily by political and
military ambitions and the promise of
the economic and commercial trade and
banking rewards that would accompany the
establishment of a Latin kingdom in the
Middle
East." So, there you have it. more
flagrantly fake history. All in the
usual service of demonizing Christians
and making victims of Muslims, even
though in reality it was the Muslims who
were tormenting and massacring
Christians. But since the latter dared
fight back, they must forever be
condemned lest their modern-day
descendants, you get any wild ideas.
Incidentally, the importance of all this
is less that professors such as John
Espazito or Francis Peters distort
history to demonize Christians and
victimize Muslims, but that theirs is
the mainstream narrative. After all,
Espazito's book, where all the
aforementioned lies I quoted, come from,
Islam, the straight path, was published
by the extremely prestigious Oxford
University Press, ensuring that
countless students of history will read,
embibe, and spread its lies.
[Music]